así
ahora que ya entendieron la idea básica
vamos a divertirnos un poco empezaremos
por agregar otro control en pixar a
estos les decimos variables de animación
o bars para cortarlo este haber escala
la pelota en x y lo encogen jr
podemos controlar el tiempo de estar
usando el mismo editor de curvas
ahora podemos hacer que la pelota se
estire al bajar y que se encoja cuando
golpea el piso
esta idea de encoger y estirar es uno de
los principios clave de la animación
y animar como se encoge y estira un
objeto nos ayuda a comunicar de qué
material está hecho
recuerden nuestro trabajo como
animadores no solo es mover las cosas
sino también darles vida una forma de
hacerlo es mostrar el proceso de
pensamiento del personaje
si esta pelota está viva entonces quizás
no solo está rebotando tal vez se está
saltando antes de saltar se encogerá con
anticipación igual que como un niño se
encoge antes de dar un salto
esto es un poco de la verdadera magia de
la animación tomamos un objeto que es
fundamentalmente inanimado y le damos
vida
sí
qué tipo de pelota quieres animar qué
está haciendo qué está pensando
puedes darle vida